every high school drug dealer looks the
same
none of them there is no no
crime person is worse at disguising
themselves
than a high school drug dealer first of
all they all have like
a name like spoony juicy tate
uh little danny bruh ledan
you know uh uh boof
um you know they all got the same type
of name
they all wear like kind of that
tracksuit
slicked hair with maybe that caesar cut
chain
and they all drive like a fancy car
like they all and there's no you're like
oh that's
the drug dealer like why doesn't the
high school drug dealer
try and look not like a drug
dealer how hard would it be for you to
get a freaking sombrero dog get a little
uh tag that says uh manager
you know or even mange or misspell it
who gives a [ __ ]
get a freaking name tag get a job at
books of millions man
damn bro you know every drug dealer
unfortunately looks at that oh and they
would some if they didn't wear the um
the uh tracksuit they wear the white tee
the white tee maybe timbalands or maybe
uh you know uh fatty sneakers
and speakers and they all work at a uh
like an auto sound place
all of them that's where they either
work or hang out at
and they just sell drugs to get more and
more speakers put into their car
and then here's what happens sadly the
speakers are so loud when the cops
finally
try to pull them over they can't even
hear the cop sirens
so then they get resisting arrest
because they couldn't even because the
whole system leads them to not be able
to hear
then they end up as a hard of hearing 30
year old
trying to get a ged but they never
change the style baby
they still drive the mustang they still
have the stripes down the back
dude the drug dealers in high school
sometimes they would even have the word
drugs
spray-painted or uh airbrushed
on the back of the car dude if you're
gonna sell
drugs don't write drugs on a car dock
get a overalls get a um
uh that do some disguise yourself
you know get a glasses man get a uh
um axe get an axe man
a shoulder chopper man get an axe
you know you just have to do things to
not look like a drug dealer
now if you just want to go back to high
school and buy drugs you can holler at
your boy big pet
all right slick you can holler at spoony
spotty otty ricky you know ledany bruh
so did i remember being in school and
the drug dogs came in there
and i was high as hell man i was high as
[ __ ] four gay dudes in a [ __ ] hot
air balloon brother [ __ ] high as [ __ ]
you know
you know what i'm saying if you need me
i'll be up there [ __ ] i'm a
and um i remember just i was scared of
dogs at the time
and i'm like hiding by the teacher and
[ __ ] and they thought i was all [ __ ]
up
and i was i was high but i was also
scared of dogs you know which really
kind of feel like the same thing
and uh and i asked the teacher point
blank i said well can the dog just smell
if i'm high
and he asked the policeman that was with
the dog and they said no
i said all right we good then fam we
good hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one